okay guys we are on hopefully we are on
I'm not 100% sure let's see can you
please write on the chat if you can hear
me and you can see me because I'm not
100% sure
so I want to see if everything is
working looks like I'm broadcasting but
I still don't see myself here oh I think
I
do I think you should be able to see me
and hear me I have a brand new camera
which is not Brand New by the way it's a
Logitech that I've had for over the last
10 years and I thought of using that
instead of using my uh the normal camera
the the camera that I normally use um
you know with when I do these live shows
a couple of things that I wanted to tell
you before we get into it um I shot it
down a couple of things here so this um
this live is going to last more or less
an hour and 1550 minutes to 1 hour or 30
minutes depending on the circumstances
depending on how it's going to go I
always have a lot of fun so uh I would I
would be here forever but unfortunately
I can't um then the second thing is uh
I've already written this in the chat um
as I said in the last live uh show if
you haven't done it subscribe to the
newsletter because uh there's a new
ebook that I wrote it's more than 80
Pages it comes with an AUD book it's
completely free so I'm not selling you
anything and there's a lot of tips that
we have we have structured this ebook
and audiobook according to um three
levels beginner intermediate and
advanced U
maybe some of you have already some of
you has already uh read it and just in
case please let us know what you think
about it and um what else uh I'm going
to also read some messages some
questions that someone left in the in
the community in the community space on
YouTube uh apart from the wonderful
questions you're asking me you're about
to ask me and you're already ask me here
and I'm going to use my computer and my
iPad here to look at the questions
because otherwise it gets a little bit
messy so I'm just going to start from
from Top I'm just gonna alternate top
and bottom to see how that works hi
Carlo hi hey hi everyone I can see here
from the bottom so on the computer I see
the bottom of
the of the chat and on my iPad iPad I
see the top so let's start
um Balon Brett says well so handsome you
look like George Clooney Italian George
Clooney so George cleani that's
funny I wish I wish um I'm getting old
but that's
fine uh so this is funny so uh let's
start with Neil Carney on Instagram in
December you said maintaining languages
is hard being honest with yourself is
even harder could you elaborate on this
I'm just I just think that polyglots
learn languages e more easily because
they know how to learn languages and
they have a lot of languages under their
belt so it's easier in a way to learn
more languages but it's more and more
difficult to maintain these languages
because the more languages you have
under your belt the more kids or
children within your family you have to
take care of and that's something
difficult to do and the second thing is
being honest with yourself means that
you recognize your limits and you tell
yourself okay well I have so much time
this amount of time and I can do only so
much so you we have to recognize that
we're the problem when people for
example ask questions such as how many
languages can a person learn in their
life in their lifetime the answer is it
depends um you know it's it's limited
because we're Limited in time and space
I don't think we're necessarily Limited
in the amount of uh languages that we
could possibly learn but unfortunately
again we don't have much time on this
beautiful planet so let me go through
some of the other questions here on top
I do three on top three at the bottom so
hello Luca from M Moscow can I ask you
some questions yeah the answer is yes
we're here to answer questions um Alonso
hello I've been learning the language
with a capital l like the moon with a
capital M the language on my own for
seven months I guess you're referring to
English but i' like to improve my
grammar what books recommend for English
what books do you recommend for English
and then also also what and then the the
the question doesn't doesn't continue so
I'm not sure I'll fun what what you
meant but if if the question is I've
been learning English for seven months
what resources should I
use um you you wrote here I'd like to
improve my grammar well the answer is
get a lot of input I know I tend to
repeat myself but get as much input as
possible input that you find interesting
comprehensible and Rich that has
contained means vocabulary that you
don't know so you learn more and more
words and if you want you can for
example now nowadays you can use um
tools like chat GPT you have um you know
doubt about some grammar aspects all you
can do is you copy and paste into chat
GPT and you ask take this text and
explain the grammar to me just an
example I'm doing uh things like that
when it comes to Turkish and by the way
guys this is not the last live uh
YouTube but it's the last one of this
sort in the sense that from from the
next one we're going to use a different
broadcasting software so it's going to
be even cooler I can share my screen and
I can share more of what I do I love
answering questions I love talking for
the sake of you know replying to your
questions but I I think it's important
also to show some stuff you know to show
you how I learn and I think you can you
know you can learn a thing or two about
about this about the techniques that I
use so um let me see the last third
question from the top um someone asked
me to do uh a British British action but
this is not actually my this is a
different action you have to actually
figure out what action that is I'm
changing a little bit but the you know
the the bottom line is that I can change
accents but it it really depends on on
the accent I can do some is better than
others it really depends on
context okay so um let me go down are
you finally revealing that you're a fake
polyot this is still bul in breath the
same guy who asked me who told me that
I'm so
handsome but uh well you know the story
about the fake polys is a very
interesting one I would
say um but I'm not sure my scsh accent
is St but uh thank you very much uh if
you guys are interested it what we can
do is actually you can do a video where
I speak in different accents I've never
done it I've really never done it
unfortunately on YouTube but I can do
that and I can change a you like
Australian is going to be a little bit
difficult but in just like as in a
nutshell I can do some oxin oxin oxin is
not good anyway so um you have any tips
material or something to start learning
Portuguese I am Max though it depends on
the kind of Portuguese you want to learn
my answer would be yes so you can get
for example resources like Asim or
there's other resources for beginners I
would start using Asimo Brazilian
Portuguese you can start with that focus
on that one resource for three months
and then you can Venture into more um
you know the the amazing amount of
content that you can find on the
internet I will start with just one
resource I always say that less is more
especially when you're a beginner true
we have a lot of tools and you could
retort that yes you can use an app and
then you know some material like paper
and then you can use this and then you
can use that but that leads to confusion
I would I would rather use just one
resource stick to that one for three
months and then move on to the next
resource so
um let me see is there hope for language
jobs in the future Fernando says I know
we do this for fun I think so uh I think
that artificial intellig is going to get
better and better when it comes to
translating there there will come a time
actually it's already come where we can
communicate just by holding a phone and
just saying something and that that the
machine is going to translate uh
immediately but I think that there's
always need for human interaction within
the language learning sphere and when it
comes to to working so yes machines will
replace a lot of work jobs but I think
there's
still um time and space for language
related jobs um Antonio have you learned
a language without a tutor that's an
interesting question yes um but I yes I
have like German I've never really had a
tutor but I talk to my friends I see my
my friends as tutors in a way the people
along the path that I've met right ma ex
my ex German girlfriend for example she
was not my tutor but she corrected me
she I talked to her I practiced uh I
practice German with her so I've never
had an official tutor but I've had
friends and people help me improve my
germ along the way that's how it always
works when it comes to learning
languages all the people you will meet
in your life will be will give you will
give some sort of contribution to your
language
skills let me go up now otherwise I'm
just going to skip a bunch of questions
that were asked
before um glad to see you can hear me
and see meotti again reading
uh here um how would you recommend a B2
learner who stopped learning this
language in my case Chinese to continue
the journey kind of lost motivation and
love to learn this is a very interesting
question
Richard and um it's not easy to go back
to learning a language that you dropped
truth be told for example in my case
Danish I started learning it some time
ago and then I lo kind of lost
motivation I think one simple thing you
can do is just connect with something
related to that language the best would
be to go to that country to to go to
China and talk to people experience like
speaking Chinese and experience the
culture behind it or connect with the
person because I think that could help
you find the motivation again language
learning never happens in a vacuum and
then sometimes we tend to learn just for
the sake of learning and then we forget
about the real we forget the real reason
why we're learning that language so my
suggestion would be do something that
connects you with China and Chinese
could be going to China if you can't go
go to China find a Chinese person you
can talk to go to a Chinese club or they
speak Chinese do anything that can in
real life that can help you uh go back
to that language connect you like
emotionally with the language because if
you lack the emotional connection then
you can you can have an intellectual
connection with the language but it
ain't GNA cut it as they
say so um when you invite Steve Coffman
for an interview we had a couple of
interviews already I can invite him
again if you guys want you decide what
we're what what we can talk about and
then we're going to make it happen is it
reach gabber asks is it possible to
reach native life fluency in a certain
language without living where this
target language is spoken if so could
you give me some could you give us some
tips very interesting question gabber I
think that's her name right gabber
Oliver um I think it's possible to reach
native like um fluency in any language
without necessarily living in the
country but you have to spend a
conspicuous amount of time with native
speakers in order to reach native life
fluence because it's not just about
listening and reading which is great but
it's also the human interaction and
there's a part of linguistics that is
called pragmatics that has to do with
how the language is used it's not just
mere words and and sentences it's really
how you use language to communicate
within a cultural environment that
provides that linguistic Knowledge and
Skills that Define native like fluency
so living in country helps if you live
in say Germany France etc etc but
spending time with native speakers and
and finding yourself in as many
situations as possible is what really is
going to make the difference So my
answer to you gabber is that if you want
to reach native like fluency in language
you have to consume a lot of interesting
content authentic content but you also
have to live the language and have as
many experiences as possible in that
language with adults with children you
know finding yourself in as many
situations as possible interacting with
one adult with many adults seeing how
adults interact with children for
example I will never forget when I was
in um in France that um I saw the
interaction between my ex-girlfriend my
ex friend's girlfriend and her niece she
was like 10 and she was asking questions
that you will throw around when you're
like nine or 10 right uh so for example
she said let me let me
remember CH something you asked me an
impossible question
it's just a typical expression a French
expression so you learn things when you
really live the situations and this is
what happened as far as I'm concerned in
France I was for many years with my
ex-girlfriend and I used to spend a lot
of time with her parents and we watched
movies we used to um talk about theater
literature Cinema French and language
saas as they say so I learned a bunch of
things uh that I would not have learned
if I had had never been to France or um
you know lived in France but I learned a
lot just by talking to my my
ex-girlfriend while I was in Italy so
you can learn obviously living in the
environment within a family is top is
the best of the best that you can get
when it comes to reaching native like
proficiency but it's not always possible
actually it's kind of difficult for most
of us it's it's not a
realistic um
solution so
uh let me see hello from Slovakia hello
Yan um can you recommend something to
learn French pronunciation Abdul says
I'm not sure if I don't see the rest but
something is a little bit vague would
you mean like YouTube channels there's
an amazing YouTube channel um but I
don't remember the name about regarding
specifically French pronunciation but if
you type French pronunciation YouTube
channels on on on on Google you will
find quite a few there's quite a few
when it comes to French if you're
learning French you have a like if
you're learning English or Spanish or
you know these very common um languages
you have a lot of stuff for
pronunciation vocabulary uh especially
courses about pronunciation really
interesting so um let me see here let me
go up just
uh up to see if there's other
interesting questions on top and then
I'm just going to go to the bottom again
um heroic at which level would you
recommend beginners to start learning
grammar really
interesting so the the Logitech works
that it refocuses if I approach like if
I for example I hope this is not going
to
miss the camera I I don't know if you
guys can see it it should refocus in a
little bit let me see so this is aimil
Turkish I don't know if you can see it
you should get an idea now it's focusing
again you should be able to see so this
is the text in Turkish and then you have
the text in Italian on the other side
and these are old grammar notes that you
can see here and I'm a beginner in
Turkish so basically I started learning
Turkish 20 26 days ago on the 1 of
January and I started learning grammar
from the get-go but you learn grammar
from language what does it mean it means
that this kind of courses here I find
them great it's called Asim because the
philosophy is assimilate a language
don't just learn a language so assimil
it's a French company and the philosophy
behind this kind of method is you listen
to dialogues you read dialogues and then
you read the notes not the other way
around so you you see grammar in context
so to answer the question um you learn
grammar from the get-go but you learn it
from from from language this is my this
will be my answer so there's never a bad
time to learn grammar or a good time to
learn grammar you always have to learn
grammar but if you want to speak if you
want to speak uh a language well and
it's interesting that in a language like
Russian means to speak a language well
but also to do things
wellat um you have to learn the grammar
you have to learn
this the grammar rules but it's always
about how you learn right it's not
whether you should learn grammar or not
because of course if you want to speak
well you have to learn grammar it's how
you learn as a beginner you learn in a
certain way as an intermediate learn in
in another way and as an advanc you
learn it in a different way but you
learn it throughout the learning
process
um Travis Jacobson asks hey LCA have you
ever learned any Hebrew and the answer
is no but I have asked meal for Hebrew
and I want to learn Hebrew so I started
Turkish the next one is most probably
Hebrew and I'm super excited I've been
watching FAA I don't know if you guys
have ever watched FAA on Netflix it's
this very cool show uh and I've watched
the first two seasons and I like to
watch the third one and um I I think the
language is pretty cool Arabic and
Hebrew they're both super cool languages
Semitic
languages Joel says oh
wow so um not exactly but I think the
chat GPT he converted himself like
conversion like a religious conversion
to chat GPT no but I use it as a tool
I'm using it and I'm having fun actually
I'm writing a guide this is a spoiler
I'm writing an entire guide on how to
use Jud GPT as a beginner and um and
this is cool and you can use chat GPT in
many ways and if you have you know if
you think about the amazing
possibilities that you can that that
chpt offers just just it's just
mind-blowing but you always have to use
it as something onp on as a the cherry
on top so to speak it's always language
learning no matter the technology no
matter the technology Revolution that
we're experiencing it's always very
simple listen as much as possible listen
to content that you find comprehensible
interesting and slightly challenging and
then you can use chat GPT mid Journey
whatever you know whatever you want but
first rule is get input that you like so
uh try says your Scottish accent is
Stellar I'm also good at Impressions
thank you very much Jeremy says Scottish
yeah I'm supposed to be Scottish this
for fun okay I already answer this um do
you have any tips materials something to
start learning Portuguese already answer
this can you do also different Italian
accents yes I can but if I speak Italian
here I'm going to lose some people
because people do not uh will not
understand I I think they will not
understand I'm not sure I can do a sound
accent as well this is more like like an
you know from Dixie Land how they called
it I don't know whether in America call
it Dixon land but that's that's that's
what it's supposed to sound like sound
like sometimes not not all the
time uh let me see
um uh oh boy what language do you dream
in Rebecca Clyde says um normally in
Italian or English I think these are the
two dominant languages and I it happened
that I I I had dream dreamed in a lot of
languages uh in I think all of my
languages but mainly in Italian English
uh
chus sounds like a Latin name which
foreign language do you feel more
related to I guess you want to say U all
of them they all belong to humankind and
I'm related to all of them I love I love
them all but I find Russian
Greek Uh Russian and Greek particularly
and German to particularly endearing and
nice to
learn uh Juan Torres how do you approach
grammatical cases and inflections I have
a uh an entire video no I'm not sure
it's a video but I have an entire
article on my blog if you write how to
learn grammatical cases look at blog you
will find it but in a nutshell I consume
a lot of content and then I see these um
cases in context and then you can use
colors for example to you can highlight
them use colors in order to for them to
stand out a little bit more and pay
attention and then I use them I get
corrected and then I improve uh in you
know with time I know this is kind of a
simplistic answer but if you want to go
more in depth just take a look at the
just type those words on on on Google
and you will find an an in-depth article
about
that um
so
um let me see uh hello from Slovakia
this I read it
again uh please rate your time spent in
France on a scale of one to 10 welcome
breath has very interesting questions I
would say I would give it a 10 um
without a doubt I've been treated very
well um I remember I had a I had a
fantastic time everywhere I went um we
had this idea that parisians are kind of
cold they're always they're always in a
in a in a hurry I found people lovely
yes it's a hectic City there's a lot of
people but I remember very lovely
conversation especially when I got into
I don't know for whatever reason
um you know when I went to got inside
Pharma I started telling the story in my
life and people loved it for whatever
reason can you imagine hey I gotta buy
something and then all of a sudden you
start talking about your problems in
your life and then conversation ensues
whatever 20 minutes 30 minutes and
clients go like what is this guy talking
about and this really happen true story
so to answer your question a I would
give it a 10 per is fantastic I'm going
to go back to Paris I think I'll fly to
tenifa I think because I haven't I
haven't bought the tickets yet but I
would like to go to tenifa and then from
there to Madrid or Barcelona and then to
Paris again I haven't been four years
and I kind of miss
it so
um let me see here let's go to the
bottom right now because there's a lot
of questions
coming um so let me see Tiana says she
must have asked the first question going
have to go up
now
um Bal and breath in serving asks do you
prefer cats or dogs both I would say
it's like asking me do you like do you
prefer mom or dad I like both I would
say uh cats are independent
lovely cat dogs are even more lovely but
they entail us a number of things know
you have to take care of them and you
have to walk them first thing in the
morning at 6 when it's cold at stuff
never had a dog had a lot lot of
cats um well that was Russian well
you're
right
isak you're
right I didn't I didn't know you know um
you didn't know you you knew Russian
welome breath I you new
serpent um
so uh let me see here when do you start
speaking votti asks and how much time do
you dedicate in a certain language
before you move on to another one wow
these are Big questions so when I start
speaking it really depends on the
language and as far as I'm concerned I
normally start speaking after at least a
year even if a language is easy or you
know close like Spanish for me or
Portuguese I wait I like waiting to get
the language in me but I know that if I
wanted to I could start speaking a
language earlier rather than later
especially when it's very similar if a
language is more distant and uh this
Turkish is definitely a distant language
I would wait uh months if not even a
year or even more than a year because
I'm not in a hurry I'm not in a hurry to
speak immediately and I know that it
takes time to get the language in me
before I speak so it really depends it
can be nine months 12 months 18 months
or even two years before I start
speaking it depends on the number of
circumstances I like
speaking I I like getting a good inside
grasped language before I start speaking
so that's that's the first answer the
second one
is um let me see how much time do you
dedicated on a certain language before
you move to another this is also a
complex you know answer to give but I
would say in a nutshell and and and to
be brief um I would say around two years
because I always make sure that I learn
more languages that that I I when I
learn more languages and I start a new
language I want to make sure that I also
maintain the other ones for example now
I added Turkish I added Turkish to the
family the the the newborn just join the
family and the problem is that now I'm
trying to learn four languages at the
same time every single day and
something's got to give so I have four
languages that I'm actively learning and
on top of that I use six seven or eight
every day or try to use them every day
in different ways and that's a lot to
take for my for my poor mind so I was I
told myself I want to learn Turkish I
want to learn Turkish I want to learn
Turkish and then I waited two years
before learning Turkish because I knew
that if I had started learning Turkish
say two years prior then it would have
been a disaster learning Turkish and
Serbian at the same time so I learned
serban for two years and now I added
Turkish to the group of languages
Vladimir or Vladimir asks what about
minimal pairs um what do you want to
know about it because you know I've
never really used minimal pairs or doing
like in the sense that I've never done
exercises I don't know if you guys know
what minimal pairs are but basically are
words that are very similar but they
differ for example for there's a
syllable that is different now nothing
comes to mind you guys can help me but
I've it it to me it's irrelevant meaning
that when you get a lot of input then
you listen to the language and then you
read and listen at the same time then
your mind naturally learns how to
differentiate you know minimal
pairs so L Lucian Mora asks how are you
doing I'm I'm from Brazil and follow
your channel and your tips how many
language you speak interesting questions
it's always it's always difficult to
answer such a question that it looks
easy but it's not that easy because if
you answer oh I speak 16 languages
people are going to think oh this guy is
just boasting about 16 languages and if
you say uh well I speak some languages
then you have to go into details of
which language you speak well which ones
you imagine you you you stumble upon
someone in a bar and you know the topic
Falls on languages and you start hey I
speak this because I speak this I've
been learning this and then that it
would be the most the most boring
conversation ever so to answer your
question I've been learning 16 languages
actually 17 with Latin and I speak some
of them flly some of them less fluently
and some I'm forgetting because I'm not
taking care of them because they're the
adults of the family the left left the
house and they are living their own life
so to speak if you want to keep uh use
that metaphor of the
so
um Tiana asks CA again I missed the
first
one is there a possibility to record a
learning session together with the tutor
yes I've been thinking of recording
three conversations one in Greek one in
Serbian and one in Hungarian and then I
will well I will not tell you this is I
won I won't spoil the surprise but yes
we were thinking about that that and
many other things different lives from a
different with a different BR broadcast
software and a lot of uh other
interesting things that we want to show
you this year because the time has come
as they say
so uh let me see here if you guys have
other questions yes you have a bunch of
other questions uh what do you do on a
daily basis to maintain the level and
all the different languages you're able
to speak H or H depending some friends
say pronounce it hambush others
hok
um I would say um that I I've already
answered this question and it's a very
recurring question but the bottom line
is that I I've based my I I use
languages on on a daily basis for work
it's my job and also on top of that I
use them on a on an everyday uh basis
every day like I watch the news in
French or in Russian while I'm cooking
that then when I'm taking a shower with
my airpods if I don't have to wash my
hair as I did today this was the
exception um then I listen to a specific
podcast um Series in Polish so it's
Polish Russian and and French basically
every day then at home I speak Polish uh
then I speak Italian with my friends I
speak Spanish um and German at work so I
I use six or seven languages either
because I use them with people around me
with my friends out in you know in the
apartment or uh outside and on top of
that I read a lot of magazines I read a
lot of books and every room of the
apartment I like thinking that every
room has a different energy and I in
every room I do a different activity and
I connected with a different language
and I've buil I've been doing this for
years so let's say that on a daily basis
I use between six and 10 languages
that's that's what allows me to use use
uh and use the languages I speak well
which I call languages of system one
languages I speak fluently at least at a
B2 level and then I learn sit down and
actively learn for more which are
according to my stalker here Balon
breath Hungarian Greek Serbian and
Turkish Uh Kevin French which
grammatical feature in a language
surprised you the most to learn about
interesting um I got to tell you the
truth as of now now nothing comes to
mind uh because there's so many
grammatical features that surpris Me
Maybe cases when I was learning Russian
and I did not know anything uh about
Slavic languages that was the beginning
I was telling myself what is this but in
retrospect I already could speak I I I
already had already learned Latin I
think maybe Hungarian had surprising had
a surprising feature for example to to
now it's difficult to explain but um a
verb takes a form depend depending on
whether uh it's it's followed by other
parts of language so that that is a
unique feature of Hungarian and many
others every language has its quirks
whether it's grammar pronunciation or
syntax Justin Justin right which ones do
you get did you get C1 or
higher um
so I would say Justin again this is a
difficult question I'll let other people
decide but in general I think I have a
high l
in English Italian Italian is my native
native language obviously English French
Spanish German Italian I would also say
Russian and Polish Russian back in the
day I used to speak it much more now
much less and polish I use I use it on a
daily basis so I think these are the
languages in which I have I would say a
high level C1 I'm not sure because in
order to assess it's really difficult to
gauge the level by the end of the day to
me these are all labels if when I'm able
to use a language either in real life or
just you know in real life in general
when when I'm able to function in every
situation I consider myself fluent and I
don't I don't I don't care about labels
anymore so to speak it becomes an
intellectual challenge as a different
matter okay just a reminder as I told
you before I'll do this two more times
one in the middle one at the beginning
one at the middle one at the end if you
guys uh have just joined us now um I
have written another book apart from the
ebook that is already online and we're
going to put on Amazon so we're going to
have the paperback uh I have have
written another book which is um
contains a lot of tips about the
mistakes you have to avoid when it comes
to learning a language both for
beginners intermediate Learners and even
Advanced there tips even for advanced
Learners so uh it the the ebook there's
an ebook that you can download so if you
subscribe uh to the newsletter you can e
more very easily download the book which
is contained in the first email that you
get and then you can also
download the audiobook just in case
you're not a reader or you don't like
reading you can just listen to it with
my soothing voice hopefully it's
soothing I'm not sure so um okay let's
go back to the questions uh muffin Smith
what does a private lesson from you look
like you will know very soon here on
YouTube when I publish uh uh the video
and the video actually the
videos Ahmed V hope I pronounce it uh
right this sounds very Turkish how's it
going with Turkish I can help you if you
want Ahmed thank you very much for the
help it's going wonderfully well I love
every single moment I spend with this
language first thing in the morning my
morning routine is always the same wake
up today I woke up at 4:30 I don't know
if you are early risers early birds or
night owls but I wake up very early and
the very first thing that comes to my
mind apart from breakfast when I'm
hungry is Turkish and I'm loving every
moment of it I'm spending one hour a day
uh using this beautiful luchuk it's it's
a French version because there's no uh
Italian version but so happens I can
speak French so I can use
that um
so my stalker Balan breath says
showering with airpods Miss of
f which means you have to talk to you
have to go see a doctor immediately I
got to talk to a psychiatrist in America
I think I call it
shrink
so uh muffins says would you recommend
lading Spanish to Portuguese or would
you just get confused I would just I
would just avoid doing that you can
there's a nice term lading but I I
depending it depends on a number of
factors I would not do that because you
kind of confused two languages I
think so
um perk asks if the Italian government
called and say yo Luka you need to go up
into a spaceship and learn the language
of these giant flesh aen squid aliens
would you go well the answer is is I'm
not sure but I think I'll give it a try
because it's really interesting and
really passionate about going to like
space in general the universe so I think
that's uh I knew that my my stalker
Balon breath would have loved the
question I love the question myself I
can tell you that's yes I I would I
would give it a go Robin are you still
learning Dutch uh answer is nope I ain't
learning Dutch no more but
uh um use it sometimes when um when the
moment comes for example if I meet some
friends and um you know sometimes I
happen to use the language especially
when I used to live with my Dutch um
roommate we used to speak Dutch quite
often it's a language I've never
forgotten you
know uh so let's go
back Lisa thank you very much she just
said she loves my videos it's always
lovely to get some nice comments for you
guys um what do you think about teach
yourself Carlo said I used I used I used
it I used to learn Dutch and Swedish um
now I got timil so I use aimil but I
don't think it's a bad uh it's a bad
language course you know you always
should give it a try do you like it
great you don't like it there's so much
stuff out there
so um Balon breath always the same
stalker Luka have you ever had to give
up on any of your children for adoption
yes uh I had to give up on Danish on
Chinese on Japanese because I am
learning other languages so it's really
difficult for me to be able to learn all
these languages otherwise I would go
crazy something's got to give and you
have to make decisions and it depends on
the period of your life as of now I
really like Greek I really like
Hungarian I really like Serbian and I
really like Turkish so I don't have time
unfortunately to take care of more than
four children at the same time um
Muhammad Gamal how many times do you do
bilingual trans transtion for a piece of
text to material everything is in the
course just in case you're interested
Muhammad it's kind of complicated to
answer this question but the answer the
short answer is I just translate once in
from my target language say Turkish into
Italian and then from Italian to Turkish
I translate Twice first orally and then
uh in writing and this is done to
understand the language more than
memorize uh stuff and there's classic
misunderstanding how do you use
translation do you use translation to
memorize everything no use translation
in order to grasp the structure of a
language better uh rather than
memorizing because at the beginning your
infrast your linguistic infrastructure
is not that big that's the reason why
trying to um memorize a lot of words
with this just by translating back and
forth is not going to work uh that well
then once you start getting more and
more input then your mind starts
learning more and more words tend to
stick more because you're building
uh an infrastructure that allows you to
um gain more information more
easily so Aladin can you suggest some
YouTube channels to practice Spanish
listening Spanish from Spain the thing
is I haven't used um you know I haven't
been learning Spanish actively for a
long
time and uh but I'm pretty sure that if
you're right Spanish from Spain castian
Spanish YouTube or on Google best
channels you'll find quite a few
uh I think one that comes to mind is
dreaming Spanish which uh I I I made a I
did an interview with him and the bottom
line the philosophy is comprehensible
input so watch this stuff you can
understand everything he explains things
really well I would start with that one
and for the rest you can just do a
Google search you'll find a delus of um
language learning material related to
castian Spanish thank God we live in a u
in an era of abundance in an age of
abundance
uh Rebecca says excellent Saturn Aon
from Dix land thank you very much I'm
not sure that it sounds No Saturn Aon
allowed some of us learn languages to
pretend we don't live in Texas there's a
very famous line about Texas and full
metal Jack and I won't repeat it here
otherwise YouTube is gonna just kick me
out kick me out of the room are you
still using notebooks for all the
dialogues you study or have you tried
some digital tools like noan Antonio I
had this here that's the reason why I
got this nice this nice little notebook
you can do a combination of both it's
always digital and uh it's it's also
analog or paper use both you know um so
I'm I still use this I still I use uh
Chad GPT and I use Google Docs I'm
slowly um starting to use notion again I
haven't used it in a long time and we're
using it more within the smart language
learning academy now for um you know
business uh purposes rather than
personal I don't know for whatever
reason I've been experiencing some sort
of friction when it comes to organizing
things on notion but things can change
with
time um what do you think about Michelle
Thomas method thank you for your content
is always really helpful Jill gon Salish
asks um I don't think much because I've
never tried it um but I've heard that
it's a good method and if you like it
then you should go uh for it I have a
minimal like I I may may I watched a
video uh 10 years ago about Michelle
Thomas interacting with two students uh
it's my way of learning is a little bit
different I don't like just listening I
like reading and listening at the same
time but to each its own so if you like
it you should go for it
um then luuka hi thank you hi oi o not
sure can you give some tips about
Chinese pronunciation um oh this is a
long one too I would just say that just
very short answer if you want to learn
um you know um Chinese pronunciation
start with words do not start with
syllables so if you want to learn how to
say for example Let me Give an example
right if you find the you know you
stumble upon the the classic the the
usual uh sentence uh I am Chinese let's
start with this one right so if you
start with the traditional method you
would go syllable by syllable W which
means I am to be
right means
Middle country country in the Middle Ren
means person so I to be um Chinese
person or China person but if you learn
it this way it's like learning if if
imagine if you're Chinese right let's
let's flip things around and then you
have to learn I am an American and then
literally you're learning it like this I
am an
amican I am an American well an American
kid learns I'm an American because he
heard it so many times that and then he
learns I'm an American right does it
make sense so my suggestion is simple
suggestion it's more complex than that
I've written an entire uh YouTube video
uh you know I've created an entire
YouTube video I've never published but
it will see the light of the day um for
more details just in case you're
interested you can for now just check um
there's a there's an article about
Chinese tones on my blog but the bottom
line is that instead of learning sure
just learn I am
then you
say so you learning in blocks
right you learn just one sound so you
have to think oh this is the third tone
followed by the fourth tone you you
learn in pairs and then you learn to um
Aggregate and combine chunks it's more
complex than that but there's not a lot
of time to go into it but this is my
suggestion don't Focus so much on S
single syllables and single tones focus
on chunks of words I am you are etc
etc so let me see is language dabbling a
good idea if you find it fun Matthew why
not if if you find it fun if you find
anything fun be it like shadowing or
dabling with languages or like
Whispering or speaking out loud or
talking to yourself or whatever whatever
floats your boat as they say
so Justin says notion just added a
Google Calendar integration I've seen
that but I've never I haven't tasted
it thank you for your viers said gay
says thank you very much
um Christian
says graas graas Chan thank you very
much for the nice
words um Travis says when you learn
Hebrew i' love to help practice with you
I love that uh Travis and by the way I
found a channel uh there's a guy and a
girl they're a couple and they're
teaching Hebrew it looks wonderful so I
was telling myself gez this looks
amazing uh and I can't wait to start
learning Greek sorry
Hebrew uh and and enjoy what they're
doing the the amazing content they're
producing
so
um how can I improve my speaking skills
from B1 to B2 C1 Shai Amor says sorry
for Ping your your name guys and girls
uh it's just is sometimes I find it
difficult I'm not sure I tend to butcher
people's names um I would say Shai in
order to improve your speaking skills
from B1 to B2 and then on to C1 there's
two things you have to do you have to
practice a lot and this is the obvious
part of the of the answer you have to
speak and you have to speak a lot as
with as many people as possible but the
other non obvious um part of the answer
is that you have to know how to speak
it's not just okay I'm just gonna have a
bunch of conversations and I'm going to
I'm magically going to speak better um
of course practice makes perfect
practice makes you fluent but what what
makes you more eloquent is just the kind
of practice that you get in in in this
in this particular circumstance I
believe that the way you practice is
really important let me give you an
example if you go and grab a beer with
your friends right just around the
corner you're going to have a
conversation and say French right what
language you're learning let's say
you're learning French I don't know what
what language you're learning then you
practice you're using the language for
communication purposes but if you want
to improve then you need to sit you have
to think about what to say what are you
going to tackle what kind of um topic
you want to speak maybe at at the at the
bar around the corner you're not going
to speak um about I don't know global
warming or about philosophical questions
and but with a tutor you can do that so
it's always a combination of two things
you can use the language in real life
with friends and people and you know
just for the sake of communicating and
talking about whatever comes to mind and
on the other hand you can do some
deliberate practice where you sit down
and you have a specific purpose you your
aim is to improve so you sit down you
think about a topic you talk about it
with someone you record the conversation
you get feedback and you learn um and
you learn is a consequence uh from that
it's always really important to work
with someone to get feedback to jot down
mistakes to look at the mistakes to
think about the mistakes to use the
Expressions where we made mistakes in
another conversation and to learn I know
that this is a little bit of a
simplistic answer but the but the you
know the bottom line is you have to use
a combination of speaking for the matter
of speaking you know for communicating
with people and the other one is sit
down and uh Define a purpose my purpose
is to speak within a given topic um with
someone who can give me feedback get get
the feedback analyze the feedback and
improve upon
that so
um again to stalker Balan breath is asks
very interesting uh questions would you
ever by the way I'm kidding he's not a
stalker he's a friend of mine but he's a
little bit quirky would you ever use
movies as study material if so give us a
quick example of how please would you
ever use movies as study material um
four demonstrations if you guys like it
again next from um from next month we're
going to do live videos where I'm going
to share my screen so you will see
directly what I do when it comes to uh
you know using movies as study material
but the bottom line and the short answer
welcome breath is yes I use movies as
study material and I'll will show you
how so
um Muhammad says when you reach B2 level
a B2 level what kind of method and
technique do you use to improve your
language well the bottom the the the
short answer Muhammad is I consume a lot
of content from movies you know watching
movies reading books watching series
talking to people and I improve upon
that again it's a little bit of a
simplistic answer but the the question
is pretty
broad Luis Garcia how to avoid
interference between Spanish and
Portuguese it's unavoidable you're going
to experience some interference and uh
and and that's going to last the you
know for the rest of your life I I know
this sounds a little bit tragic but it's
not tragic you know the fact that we we
experience some interference between
languages is is part of life so um
my answer would be in order to let's say
minimize this kind of interference I
think you should practice both languages
give importance to both languages again
bearing with the metaphor of the family
it's just like having two children and
then you're if you give much more
attention to one instead of the other
the other suffers so and and then you
start they start you know throwing toys
and doing this and then maybe they punch
at each other and as a parent you go
like oh my God what's go what's what's
happening so if you give them kind of
the same care of you know you take care
of both of them then you're going to see
that there's less interference I know
this sounds very strange but that's how
it
works and especially if one is more
dominant in my case Spanish is much more
dominant than than uh Portuguese so I do
not experience any interference from
Portuguese but I do interfere I do I do
feel that when I speak Portuguese my
Spanish comes to the four because I use
it much more and it's speaking much
better so it's like the big brother the
punches a little brother for the little
little little daughter uh Alejandro says
avoiding interference is very difficult
yet not impossible but maybe but in my
case I think that you have to put a lot
of effort into it and if you want to the
question is always is The Game worth the
candle so is it worth putting the effort
in order to minimize the effort if your
answer is yes then go for
it so uh let me see if you have any
other answers yes you have questions you
have a lot um
Rebecca asks please tell me which of
your videos do you recommend for someone
who I know would love your content but I
need to convince them to watch one to
get it bit by the by the Luca
bug oh boy um I'm not sure it depends on
the kind of person um on the kind of
person he is maybe you can show them the
the multilingual video where I talk in
11 languages and I give 11 tips about
how to learn languages maybe he's going
to like that but again I I cannot
foresee his reaction I have no clue but
you can you can share that one video and
let's see what
happens uh thank you for sharing you
know sharing my content
around so um Carol drawings asks can you
recommend any resources to improve
French speaking
um I do not know many resources in that
I I know resources where you can listen
and read for French speaking I've
recently stumbled Upon A an interesting
course about pronunciation but not
necessarily speaking I know the
pronunciation is a part of speaking but
I don't remember the name to tell you
the truth I would again I would say that
you can look for speaking training
French you can write something like that
keywords and then I think within 10
minutes you can for sure find an
interesting course then you take a look
at the reviews and if that suits your
needs then you you you give it a try but
more than a course about speaking I will
go for H just language classes or
conversations like the best way to
improve your speaking as I said before
is speaking and then you have two
different forms of practicing so that's
what I would do I would just hire a
tutor on I talkie cambly uh preply or
prle I think it's the name and start
speaking that's the way you improve
improve your speaking by speaking I know
it sounds really easy but that's the way
that's the way it is why Spanish and
Greek sounds almost the same Antonio
speo asks God only knows but uh they do
and I made a video in Greek which I'm
GNA publish very soon talking just about
that the first time that I heard two
Greeks speak was in the street and I
thought oh these are like drunk Spanish
people they speak in a very weird way
what's going on then I found out that
they were actually from Greece and the
same thing happened uh I've been
learning Russian for quite some time and
I was just like listening to two
Portuguese people from Portugal I say oh
these are Russian people but maybe they
speak a dialect I've never heard this
kind of Russian that's kind of weird and
they turned out to be
Portuguese because
Portuguese so I just said Portuguese
people they kind of eat all the the
vowels go and go to instead of saying
for example toas toas which we would say
in Spanish they say
because the unstressed syllables you
know you don't pronounce the vowel which
may makes the language sound very
interesting so um let's see um how do
you switch between languages during a
conversation Vladimir Vladimir Vladimir
zenovic asks perhaps there is some
secret there's just the secret is
practice you polyoses or speaking people
who speak multiple languages can switch
from one language to the other by
practicing and there's a I once was at
the conference that I met a very
interesting guy who happened to be a
polyot and a neuroscientist who told me
that I don't know whether this is true
or not but I took him you know I I
believe he was telling me the truth
because he's a neuroscientist According
to some research you have a switch a
language switch Center in your brain so
the more you stimulate it the more
you're able to actually switch from one
language to the other and languages are
distributed um
along um you know all over your brain
and uh it you know according according
to what I read is that a guy for example
a guy I think it was a girl she was hit
by something I don't remember exactly
the details but she lost her native
language and she kept another language
she had to learn as a second language
which is pretty amazing and that was
proof enough evidence enough that uh
maybe her native language was stored in
a place that was not hit uh you know was
not involved in this accident which I
find absolutely fascinating and it
recently watched a very interesting um
documentary about bilingualism in
Spanish talking about the different
language centers it's just amazing to
watch and
experience Dennis Dennis pisto asks do
you think share talk was a good resource
uh I don't know whether it was a good
resource or not it was more like place
where you can practice language I had a
lot of fun though I had a lot of fun
speaking Chinese like going to random
rooms for those who are not old enough
to know what sh talk is or maybe they
have never um they never knew
they were around but they never got to
know what this was it's just a space
where you can practice languages mainly
by writing but then you could also call
people I had a lot of fun back in the
day calling random Chinese people uh all
day basically that was in 20 2010 I
think wow 14 years ago
Jesus anyway
um let me see here uh some other
questions
um do you know some Japanese jel asks uh
I do but it's very Rusty and uh that's
one of the you know my biggest language
regrets that I didn't go back to
Japanese it's just like a a lady a very
cute girl that I was trying to flirt
with and I was trying to date and she'
just turned me down but I will go back
to it with a Vengeance as they say uh
when the moment comes when I feel that
the moment comes because I haven't uh
given up on my dream on the dream of
speaking Japanese nor have I given up
the dream of speaking Chinese the
Chinese is going to be easier to go back
to Chinese because I feel like I'm Rusty
but I can go back to it pretty easily
Japanese is different it's different
matter but we'll see uh but the answer
is I can speak a little bit of Japanese
as now very Rusty but if I if I work on
it for a few days I can after sentences
and but again uh it's a lady that turn
me down and um I'll I'll go back to
floring with her and dating her in a
couple years let's
see so uh do you use tandem or hello
talk Antonio speo asks and the answer is
no because I tend to I prefer speaking
with people rather than just chatting so
but I've never used T so I don't know if
you can actually speak with people but
the answer is I don't chat I prefer
speaking but I spend so much time on on
the internet already that I tend to I
prefer speaking to people in real life
rather than you know talking on Zoom or
type I do that with tutors but not
necessarily with friends I have I have
developed an allergy to speaking with
people online because we spend so much
time in front of the screen
already someone said but I don't
understand Spanish I know it's Greek yes
and in English you have this expression
It's All Greek to me meaning I don't
understand I don't understand much right
um in Italian we
sayab so when you say it's
Arabic means are you speaking Arabic
literally it means uh it's it's Greek to
me I don't understand
anything uh okay so um o o I'm not sure
how to pronounce your word your name O I
don't know where you're from interesting
name is it better to read a book
translating to the desired language that
I have already read or to read books
written originally in desired language I
would say both why don't you do both one
is for facilitating reading you know the
the act of reading in that language and
the other one is to enjoy the book so I
would say both um I would say learn it's
always always approach any activity with
a purpose so the purpose is enjoying the
book is one thing if the purpose is to
learn by approaching something is
slightly challenging then maybe you can
read a book that you have already read
in your native language that you know
well because if you know the plot is
really going to help it's just like
watch the same concept applies to movies
you watch a movie you already watched it
you know the plot you already know the
actors and it's really easier to
um to watch it in in your foreign
language for example if it's dubbed in
your foreign language or the other way
around so um you guys we have still 15
minutes uh I hope I answered most of
your questions I know that it's getting
late but I'm I'm doing uh the best I can
uh is it worth is it worth it today's
studying Dutch how often you use it
daily Spirit satura asks uh is it worth
uh studying Dutch if it's worth it's
worth learning Dutch if you find it
worth learning Dutch there's millions
and millions of people can speak Dutch
and if you want to live there you want
to you know you have friends I think
it's definitely worth it but asking is
it worth learning a language in a vacuum
I I don't think it's
necessarily um the the correct question
that you should ask yourself you should
ask yourself is it worth learning Dutch
for me and for what
reason Tiana says wait I'm getting lost
here between the chat here on my
computer and and
my asks do we need to express ourselves
uh fluently in every single topic to
consider yourself fluent in a language
and the answer is no because we're not
fluent in any topic imagine that we got
to talk all of a sudden I'm a Time
native time and have to talk about
rocket science right I'm gonna be lost
I'm gonna be at a loss for words because
I don't know my well I do a thing or two
about rocket science but let's because
I'm an engineer but let's consider I
don't know something very specific
specific topic about say biology I would
be at a loss because I don't
know that much about that specific uh
you know topic
there's always this big confusion I I
remember there was a kind of a not a
nasty guy but he was he was fun to watch
he was a little bit weird and he was
saying oh if you can't say you know um I
don't remember exactly you go to the
mechanics you got a problem with your
car you can't explain what problem what
technical problem you have then you're
not fluent and that is pardon my French
BS meaning it doesn't mean anything
right in order to speak a language FL
you have to be you know you have to
function and and within that Society the
society that speaks that language but it
even happens in our own native language
that sometimes we find ourselves at odds
because there's situations where people
use certain kind of vocabulary um that
we do not know an example a glaring
example of that is the hospital maybe
you get diagnosed with something and
then the doctor comes up with this and
that that technical term you're
completely lost and that is your own
native language so the answer is no you
don't need to know about every single
topic it's you know it's a very common
misunderstanding about language uh
ability and knowledge knowledge and
ability they're processed by different
parts of your
brain so uh o when you were learning
Chinese what was your routine rly
basically speaking to Chinese random
Chinese people all day I'm kidding on
share talk but I was learning I was
sitting down I was
learning uh basically I was learning
every day I was using askim first and I
was using link Q for those who know
Steve Kaufman the famed polyglot polyot
of fame or beloved Steve Kaufman I was
using link all the time I was listening
and reading listening and reading all
the time to and I was doing that to a a
lot of podcasts I was using a lot of
podcast you can find on the website and
uh that was great I haven't used link Q
or Link in a while uh but uh link or
link you is a wonderful resource if you
want to learn a lot of languages just
says Link and he's a he's a fan in in
our school he always posts about how
many words he knows uh how many words
he's learned on link isn't it right
Justin so I recommend Link in general I
was doing a lot of input learning
listening reading and listening
listening reading a lot and talking to
random Chinese people on chair talk for
a little for a little
bit so uh let me
see what do you think about shadowing
this is another common question I get
and the answer is I've never tried it
before uh I always tend to listen pay
attention to how language sounds when I
do my phonetic analysis which is the B
directional translation uh method we
have a course about that that is
integrated in the method where I tend to
Listen by focusing on
intonation and repetition when it when
it comes to uttering these words I
follow my own uh marks because I write
with a pencil again next uh from next
month I can show you exactly how I do
that because it's nice to see you show
you on a Blackboard directly visually or
a whiteboard how I do that instead of
just talking about it uh but I don't
I've never never used Shadow uh I think
it could be useful but it can be
done like everything you can apply it
you can use it in a good way or you can
use it in a in a sloppy way and if you
know how to use it it can be very
powerful
but I wouldn't swear by because I've
never tried it
before um then we have always the same
stalker who asks
the boy he said why why did you learn
polish is it because of girls um the
answer
is no meaning that um when I was in
Poland I fell in love with the language
and then I fell in love also with Polish
girls because they're absolutely
beautiful but that's a different matter
I fell in love with the country I fell
in love with the language fell in love
with this generation of Polish people
are just like young people but even just
everybody I just I don't know why I have
this uh this this connection with with
Poland I always when I walk down the
streets of CCO or or or or a waro uh for
that matter I always have a smile on my
face I tell myself I'm so lucky to be
here so it's not just because
copy it as as Balan breath
suggests I don't want you to think Balan
breath that I'm a womanizer I'm not I
learn I don't learn languages to pick up
girls I pick up girls to learn languages
I'm kidding so
um I'm getting more analog Luca Justin
right says got my Smart Notebook right
here uh thank you Justin uh I know that
you've left a very interesting comment
recently on our platform because we have
the you know you have the courses but we
also have an entire community of very
enth enthusiastic Learners and you said
that you're going like you're going back
to the uh watching the overcoming the
intermediate Plateau course and um to
review the material and I know that you
like uh digital stuff but a Savvy
combination of both again the internet
gives you speed uh you got access to a
lot of things but I think the paper
gives you depth so you have width and
depth at the same time and I think you
should combine uh the um
the two a muffin seems to have an
obsession about financial problems and
buying plane tickets to travel and learn
you've repeated that multiple times
muffin I don't know exactly what what
that stands for because I missed the
context but uh it's an interesting
comment um what do you think about
randomly shouting out and repeating
phrases in your target language while
walk in in public useful uh maybe not
shouting you I sometimes I talk to
myself and people don't think I'm crazy
anymore back in the day 20 years ago
didn't have airpods uh and um you know
you could pretend to be now you can
pretend to talk to yourself you have
airpods uh but I don't shout the worst
thing I've done is I was in a Metro and
I felt this terrible urge of speaking
Chinese to myself and I started speaking
Chinese pretending I was talking on the
phone and people looked at me very
quizzically thinking this guy this guy's
had it right it's like 7 o' going back
home he's very tired and he's just like
probably had a very bad that day and
he's talking himself in tongues he's
speaking in tongues so to speak Justin
says yes the overcoming the intermediate
political course is fantastic thank you
very much Justin I'm so glad to have you
all these wonderful students and glad to
hear that the you know you like the
courses we and the community you've
built and by the way last ad here before
the last the very last 10 minutes again
for those who just joined us uh if you
want to join the newsletter here um you
will get a completely free ebook and
audio book so it's written by me and I
read it with my soothing voice and the
tips range from you know tips for for
beginners tips for intermediate Learners
tips for advanced Learners trying to
cover all the phases of language
learning so um Dennis what resources do
you did you use to learn Swedish I used
teacher s Swedish and then I used asmil
and then I watched a lot of movies um
[Music]
Antonio says jot it down you don't learn
the language to pick up girls you pick
up the you pick up girls to learn
language well that's you know goes in
both directions but um at what age were
you completely fluent in English Mustafa
asks I'm not sure about completely
fluent it's really difficult to Define
what completely fluent means but I can
tell you that at the at the ripe age of
15 I was in Ireland and uh I was talking
to a guy and I this is something I
recount in the in in the book you know
in in the ebook I wrote some months ago
and then all of a sudden this guy comes
along and says he's American so he
thought I was an American and that I was
15 I've been learning the language I
start had started learning English at
the ri age of 10 and I've been learning
for two years to no avail because school
sucked and I I sucked at school and my
English sucked and and then I had this
wonderful teacher taught me who started
uh talking with me and just just you
know in English every every week it
inspired me and then two years later I
was speaking people were mistaken me for
for an American in Ireland so
um Linda uh she also says the overcoming
the intermediate P was fantastic looking
forward to the advanced course Linda
thank you very much and we are working
on it we're working on other courses now
we're working on a course on speaking
and speaking at a low level which is
going to be very exciting because
speaking for intermediate Learners it's
also cool but you know you know what you
have to do you have to talk to a tutor
talk to people but when you're just A2
that's that's a little bit different and
we're getting this course out in a
couple of months
so um so if if you uh want to know more
about this and we have another course
with a specific language for the first
time just sign up to the newsletter
because on top of the wonderful ebook
and audiobook you're also going to get
news exciting news about what we're
building right now Dory asks why
American English I would say why not
well that's the kind of English that I
got exposed to since I was a you know
basically 12 I had an English an
American tutor um came to the four when
I was 13 then I was she gave me a lot of
American movies I was watching a lot of
American movies then I had a girlfriend
she was from Chicago then I had uh
another another girlfriend who was from
Chicago and then I had like Illinois or
I you know I I
basically I've been exposed to American
English uh
a lot more than British English so
that's that's why American English I
guess uh soothing is questionable thank
you bual breath uh why American English
Doris asked already replied
um let me see here
uh it's interesting ironic I'm in the US
and I prefer British English um well
it's interesting I remember that when I
was in England um I was with a friend I
will not name the friend because some
people know my friend here I was ask I
asked her he asked his his um his granny
what do you think about American English
and she said it's stupid so that was
funny because in I I know this is kind
of this is kind of a contentious thing
um but uh I got the impression I was not
being looked down uh you know when when
I was in England but I got the
impression that the brids tend to think
that American Americans are kind of dumb
and they sound dumb while Americans tend
to think that Brits are sophisticated
there's also um I think it's Love
Actually a movie where this British guy
was kind of a loser goes to America and
gets the hot grow just because of his
accent so it's fun to watch uh I T I
tend to think that the accent doesn't
matter what matters is the person who
speaks right if you have if if you have
your personality shines you get Charisma
people like you no matter what how you
speak of course if you speak with a very
a very very thick Scottish accent that's
a different matter if I had the video
just this video the whole time just like
that not sure you like the video or like
keep watching honestly not
sure anyway so with the on this Scottish
note I would conclude this uh live
um uh live
video yes 1 hour and 12 minutes talking
without drinking water looka very
impressed water's here but I got excited
we speak a
lot um thank you very much for watching
so we'll keep it within the 1 hour 15
minute Mark couple of important things
um so I have I had promised this
um the last it was the 29th of December
that I would start doing also live
videos in Italian and in other languages
I have a couple of surprises up my
sleeve very soon you hear me speak
Italian there's going to be a live live
show Italian we're going to do more
lives and it's going to be in English
and Spanish and Italian in French and
um and you will see the changes so it's
not just me speaking I'm going to show
you stuff uh and I think hopefully
you're going to like um like the new
format I wish you all a fantastic
fabulous day evening wherever you are
all scattered in the
world and uh wish you a fantastic happy
language learning remember the
newsletter remember the ebook if you
like reading that you're going to if you
like reading if you like reading about
language learning you're going to find
the book great if you like listening and
you can listen while running some
errands or re you know uh taking a walk
with your dog or your cat then uh I
think you're going to enjoy uh the
content thank you very much um and I
will see you very very soon much sooner
than than you can
imagine Italian J
Butler bye-bye
so